hi everybody I'm Pete Holmes and I'm
here with comedies TIG Notaro he's
telling the truth let's talk about
comedy all right we like that you just
did some yeah it was
boy did I you really did it I did a few
different you really did it this time
TIG that's what I heard in your voice
like you rapscallion you really did it
this time well I'm like an old man and
you've hit a comedy baseball through my
window I did different layers of comedy
accidentally tonight I was telling a
story that was true yes about Taylor
Dayne about Taylor Dayne pop singer that
I keep running into something about you
you attract Taylor Danes to you I'm the
same way with crows really yeah the
Counting Crows yeah that guy black crows
all of the crow bands yeah are
constantly around just making me sad
this is a true story and it happened and
I know it well yes because I've seen you
tell it in the comedy clubs that we work
it's it's true and then I I went out
here and then I forgot the story yeah
you left your body yeah is what happened
I tried to you did but I was still stuck
there not knowing how the story went
there was a moment of like oh wow my
brain didn't remember at all what's
coming next
and then my brain went well this might
be an opportunity
you took a crisis and turned it into an
opportunity which is amazing no I took a
crisis and turned it into another crisis
and then it kept not I kept not
remembering and then it became another
crisis and then I was like I have a lot
of crisis see ya cry cry sorry
let me ask you about your three biggest
fears okay I understand
they're quick Sam sure that's not real
what quicksand or my fear quicksand is
not real no that's real yeah who then
fears it contracting leprosy
that's a real one you know what I guess
I've outgrown that my real fear as an
adult and to be honest I am an adult I
am fearful of being in the middle of the
ocean in the middle of the night just
bobbing that's a great one
that's my album this is you speaking
into the microphone
yeah is that your thing yeah it's the
comedy drawer I have a file cabinet in
my house yes and this is and I used to
this says dark man I used to work for
Sam Raimi the director and this used to
be his file cabinet so it said like dark
man evil dead evil dead - all his
different films and then when I took
when I left my job and took his file
cabinet without asking is that true no
great but then I put my own little thing
in that just said comedy and stuff my
friend was always amused by that and
she's a photographer and so she took
that picture it's a great back cover the
album and they're often it kind of feels
like you go to your comedy job and clock
in and there's a whistle and you don't
particularly like it there is a whistle
can I um recreate this yeah if you buy
my CD yep like hard copy yes it comes
with a DVD okay that didn't have
stand-up on it it's just me standing
still for one hour this is what I've
been told
yeah you standing are there people
amongst you no it's just me standing
there having a drink for one hour and
it's called have to get your party and
it loops you occasionally say anything
or sneeze we have to watch the video oh
I see with no spoilers yeah you have to
watch the video to find out about any
sort of sneezing or coughing or you know
there's one guy that just puts it in to
be like old Tim is not alone tonight
yeah I mean yeah you know Timmy oh yeah
yeah
good go TIG Notaro the new album oh my
god are we doing this kind of felt so
right
[Music]